Після європейського державного акту прощання
з Гельмутом Колем у Франції
труну транспортували гелікоптером до німецької батьківщини екс-канцлера.
З Людвіґсгафена тіло Коля
Рейном доправили до міста Шпаєр.
Уздовж течії стояли юрби людей –
це була можливість попрощатися з канцлером єдності.
Хоча дехто і критикував
дорогу церемонію.
Але домінували емоції вдячності.
Я сприймаю його як свого батька.
Він мав дуже батьківську ауру.
Один з моїх синів сказав, мамо, але ж він не наш батько!
А я йому відповіла, що відчуваю його батьківську ауру.
Хіба я не права?
Я прийшла, щоб згадати його та визнати його досягнення.
Це дуже емоційне відчуття. Гаразд, це вже останнє прощання.
Кульмінація дня – у Шпаєрському соборі.
Він мав для Коля великий символізм.
Тут під час війни він, за власними спогадами,
знайшов прихисток від бомб.
Коль водив сюди багатьох лідерів, котрі відвідували Німеччину.
І це стало місцем його останньої меси,
яку провів єпископ Шпаєра.
На месі також перебували поважні політики з усього світу
та німецький політичний бомонд.
На завершення панахиди -
момент тиші. Момент, коли кожен може сказати особисте
"прощавай" Гельмуту Колю.